the European Union is on the brink
anti-eu populace are making gains across
the continent and Britain could leave
without a brexit deal this week conflict
zone is in Prague where I have caught up
with Alex Stubb the form of Finnish
Prime Minister has launched a campaign
to become the next president of the
European Commission can he fix Europe
[Music]
[Music]
Alex Ellis - welcome to a conflict zone
thank you you have launched an
unprecedented campaign to replace on
Claude Juncker at the President of the
European Commission your campaign
program talks a lot about values quote
if I were to say in one word why I'm
running for Commission President it is
values do you pian values and when you
leave the European airspace no I think
actually European values are global for
me they're universal so they have to do
with human rights fundamental rights
Liberty liberal democracy rule of law
equality and tolerance so for me these
are available they are part of who we
are as human beings so they're not only
European if they are global let's talk
about a quote from jean-claude Juncker
he said the EU has links with regimes
some of which are loathsome we talked
about Turkey he said and we are right -
but never we talked about Saudi Arabia
tell me something about Saudi Arabia
well Saudi Arabia is obviously a Middle
Eastern country very oil-rich not
democratic gave the right for women to
drive cars only the past in the past few
years and right now is in the middle of
a journalist murder case so what are the
sanctions what are the ideas what is the
reaction of the EU if you would have
been the president today well I think
the main tool that the European Union
has basically are sanctions and
obviously with Russia we used them
because they annexed the Crimean
Peninsula and they have been
intimidating Ukraine and then in every
specific case we look at so a legitimacy
of yeah first thing you would do is to
basically go through what has happened
and on the basis of the evidence that
you have you get the Member States
together he clear this journalists
entered the consulate and he never came
out so there are no
really miracles what happened there and
no secrets what happened there that's
why again what's about Saudi Arabia
today from your perspective well from my
perspective I think we'd have to first
get the Member States together then put
a declaration and decide in common on
the basis of unanimity on some form of
sanctions well I think first if if this
has been if this has been a organized
official murder then action must be
taken but we don't need to wait for that
Saudi Arabia is responsible for hundreds
of thousands of victims children women
in Yemen it's a brutal war against the
civil population what should be the
answer of the European Union towards
that Massacre well it depends on which
Massacre you're talking about and by
which country I think it's very
important I think it's very important to
be I think it's very important to be
principled when it comes to foreign
policy you have to look at the whole
situation in the Middle East draw
conclusions from that and then see what
kind of relationship you have with Saudi
Arabia European relations with Saudi
Arabia or of course not as close for
instance as the Americans one American
one is the human Terrien catastrophe in
Yemen as so far has not stopped
Europeans arms shipments we are involved
in Europe with this in your opinion
should those arms shipments be stopped I
think you have to be very careful when
it comes to arms shipment and I actually
work as the chairman of the board of the
crisis management initiative which is
Martti Ahtisaari is the Nobel Peace
Laureate Center and we do a lot of work
in Yemen at this particular moment to
try to do peace mediation and of course
when it comes to arms it never helps
it's again a very concrete question to
be stopped or not these arms yes or no
actually it is not that concrete then
it's not that black and white because it
depends on well very well it depends
only depends on the arms that you're
talking about they're talking about
satellite surveillance are you talking
about the types of instruments
with this arm shipments European Union
is supporting you have to be a little
bit more Pacific you have to be a little
bit more specific than that the European
Union is not providing arms
it is Member States from the European
aim the member states that are doing it
name the name first which arms are you
talking about and which countries are
generalities start giving me some
concrete styles that you know about and
are you principally for or against a
support of Saudi Arabia arms or whatever
it is it's not I mean
foreign policy I'm afraid it's not that
binary you have to look at it from a
much broader perspective I think the key
issue when we talk about values is what
kind of values you stick to yourself and
then you have to take those decisions on
those principles so democracy
dictatorship suppressing your own
population or not being an aggressive
country and regime or not these are the
values and we are talking about the
values you want to defend in Europe so
why not in Saudi Arabia why not in Iran
for example well I think in both cases
you have to work with the country in
question and then if you find in certain
cases that there's a blatant breaking of
these values then you stop the
cooperation you mentioned Iran for
instance I think there it's very
important that we stick to the nuclear
deal that we did with Iran and that we
continue to work constructively with the
regime
I think nuclear weapons are a question
of the future of mankind and of course
if you don't deal with those then what's
the point of having values it's also a
point of double standards Iran is also
involved in a lot of massacres is also
involved in Wars is also involved in
Syria where hundreds of thousands
civilians are not living anymore
because Iran is involved there in that
so again values on one hand diplomatic
relationship on one hand but to be more
active and support these regime
how does this fit with your values well
it's of course they don't fit it's very
difficult to do and unfortunately we
don't live in a world that we all
expected would emerge after 1989 where
we will be relying or liberal democracy
social market economy and globalization
the world is not perfect it will not be
perfect but I think it's very important
that inside the European Union we work
with these values and of course try to
then export those values through
peaceful means
we know that the European Union and the
member states are exporting arms they
are sporting relationship on the
economic scale Saudi Arabia or Russia or
Egypt torture murder so tries on massive
scale and the U is still doing
businesses with those countries we are
talking now about businesses these are
the values of Europe no they are not the
values of Europe the values of Europe
have to do with peace prosperity
security and stability and we try to
work towards those every countries in
the world is not going to be German
French Finnish Swedish British or
anything for that manner but I think
it's very important that we continue to
work on the basis of our values you're
never going to get it
pitch-perfect I also must remind that
the European Union is the biggest aid
donor in the world I must also remind
that the European Union countries have
no compensation it's not I think the way
in which you're trying to present things
I find it extremely simplified and black
and white that no don't like listen
about the prospective sorry you're not
you're not listening because you're
interrupting me constantly so what I'm
trying to say is that the world is not
perfect if I had a choice we would be
based on values having liberal
democracies a social market economy and
cooperate together piece by piece the
world is becoming a better place do we
stop cooperation with everyone who
doesn't agree with us no I don't think
we know that we don't talk about
cooperation now you try to make it black
and white the question
is how intensively our European
countries and also the European Union
for example supporting businesses trade
and these are the government's and these
are the ministers who are improving all
these relation for example with the
country like China now you will tell me
again we are not China but you and the
European Union and also your country you
are supporting with coming there helping
trade for your companies that these
totalitarian system and these
governments are more in power than they
were before how does this match with the
values we are talking about it's
definitely not a perfect match but I do
think that trade and cooperation is a
way of bringing nations and entities and
areas closer together and my argument is
that we're starting to see a China which
obviously does a lot of trade do we
agree with the way in which they always
do business no but I do not believe that
we should stop doing that we support
more the population in China or the
authoritarian government if we are
coming with a lot of gifts with a love
of military cooperation with trade who
is really helped by this
I think populations more than regimes
because at the end of the day when it
comes to economic growth populations are
much better off if you look at GDP per
capita growth in China it is much
greater than it was before when China
started open as you could argue that
it's much more open society than it used
to be but it certainly is different but
the control is increasing the
dictatorship is not decreasing and we
have a real field where we can talk
about that's Russia the relations with
Russia are very complicated putting is
still suppressing his own population
there's still no democracy in Russia
Russia has annexed Crimea there is no
sign that Russia will leave that Ukraine
territory or stop supporting separatists
in eastern Ukraine
the sanctions which the EU has imposed
on Moscow do you think that they are
working what are your suggestions about
it's actually pretty much the only
instrument that we have with Russia what
you just said I think is absolutely
correct and I do think that the European
Union took a good and principled
decision by pushing those sanctions and
keeping them up my argument was of
course when I was mediating peace in
Georgia as a chairman of the OSC that
this is when Russian foreign policy
started to change and we started to see
violence and grabbing of territory again
this is what we can do with Russia I
mean we have 1,300 kilometers of border
with Russia we know a thing or two about
how to deal with the Russians I think
sanctions are the best instrument that
we have at this moment they are not
working well I would argue that they're
working look at the GDP per capita in
Russia look at the economic growth and
in such is not changing the policy
that's true but you know what do you
want us to do you do it by force I mean
you were just earlier arguing that we
should stop relations for instance with
Saudi Arabia now when I say that no
relations allowed to speak at all anyway
go ahead your question or lecture was
Europe is partly depending on energy
deliveries from Russia if you're opposed
serious wouldn't it try to wean itself
off of Russia energy delivers instead
Europeans are building more pipelines
and Russian nuclear reactors that's what
you call defending the European values
to be strong against Russia no it's
actually called an energy dependency and
I do think and I think you're absolutely
right that we need to start moving
towards more independence in energy and
you need to have that as broadly as
possible but if you look for instance a
gas distribution in eastern and central
Europe it would be impossible to cut off
the pipeline's at this particular moment
in your platform that state about
migration you state we solve the worst
migration crisis and now it is time to
show all Europeans that the situation is
under control what do you mean by
so in the sense that in 2015 we had the
biggest migratory flow into Europe since
World War two we were talking about a
million two million illegal immigrants
coming in and if you look at the figures
in 2017 and 2018 they are now at the pre
2015 level so it is much better
uncontrolled and what what does it mean
so the problem is still there you have
the war in Syria you have Afghanistan
you have refugees and by paying of
Turkey to keep the refugees three
millions of them and that's what you are
saying you solve the problem I mean
again we must stop the illusion of
utopia and that everything is perfect I
think we have mitigated and in that
sense solve the problem now it's a
question of how you administer it and of
course as you have read my program you
will see that I have three proposals on
how to deal with it in the future as
well how can you say that something is
sold if at the same time you have three
millions of refugees and you are
dependent from a dictator who is
suppressing his own population he is
doing the bad work for Europe and you
are saying that the problem is so awful
no I think what I suggest also in my
program is three things one is to have
Asylum centers outside the European
Union in order to be able to solve the
problem and of course they should be EU
funded and based on the UNHCR secondly I
suggest that we had actually have a
stronger from text 10,000 and then
thirdly I think we should have
humanitarian based the silent quotas now
will this solve the problem not
completely but it will at least
alleviate the pain and help it do I feel
that the deal with Turkey was the right
one probably it had a time and a place
do I like the Turkish regime and their
brawn no I don't do I like what they do
no I don't but right now at this
particular moment we don't have an
alternative that means pragmatic policy
is something which has the same value
like values don't understand your point
or not know what you don't like what
turkeys do you don't like the government
but you have to understand and we all
have to understand this is pragmatic
see it's very pragmatic yes we tried to
find a solution to one of the key
problems I think that we have in Europe
which is migration and I think we have
been able to mitigate it quite well I
think that we have to talk about the key
problem which means Africa which means
some Arab countries and there are
nothing is sold and therefore as you
have read my program I also talked about
the focus should be on investment in our
years and years of course it will you
know they're talking about you campaign
and your program for now you want to be
the president in the next month we are
talking about now not in fact three four
five years yeah but I mean to be quite
honest let's be realistic I have a five
week campaign and if I were to claim
that I'll solve the world problems right
now that would be absolutely ridiculous
and not not at all credible so my
argument is that what we need to do is
to have more cooperation for instance
with continents such as Africa not least
because that continent is going to have
four billion people inhabitants in 2100
so we have a lot of work ahead of us yes
another of you are of one of your
solutions from your campaign quote we
should establish a quota for
humanitarian basis eylem seekers for
each member state Hungary Poland
Slovakia have all rejected any kinds of
quota system how are you going to get
European governments to support the idea
yeah well as I'm sure you were listening
a little bit earlier I've made that
point I can repeat it if you want to
this is not about illegal immigrants as
such it's about asylum seekers who are
international humanitarian based asylum
seekers Hungary has not said no on a
humanitarian based asylum seekers this
is a key system whereby you from these
centers make some kind of a quota and if
you don't do it you can use some
flexible solidarity but Hungary has not
said no to that you have to get your
facts right if you're trying to be
aggressive in your question no to asylum
seekers and many European Eastern
European countries say that they don't
want any Muslims this is correct you
heard about that
that's it so you talk about values but
if you are the president of this
organization some of the country leaders
are saying we don't want any Muslims
this is religious discrimination isn't
it yes I would agree that I think you
know we must protect minorities we must
protect religious freedom and that's why
I talk a lot about values
but you see I think I mean the problem
that I have with your line of question
is is that you make a presumption that
the world is perfect and everyone needs
to have the same opinion I am trying my
best to improve the world and give
pragmatic solutions and the feeling that
I keep of here all the time is that you
know will not find a solution if we
don't we're doing it right away and I
think we are talking about red lines and
racism is a red line in the values and
we are now on racism so I understand
your intervention but I apologize here
is not black white and here are no
assumptions we are real reality is far
rikes and photic parties have gained
ground in this country where we are now
the Czech Republic and Austria in
Germany in Denmark in Hungary in other
Eastern European countries this is the
real Europe today and we are talking
about this real Europe and the question
is what happened in the last years and
you were also on duty you were Prime
Minister you were a part of the European
Union these are the red lines mr. Staub
yeah and I fully agree with you what
happened was probably two things one was
the euro crisis which caused a lot of
instability and the other one was the
migration crisis which caused a lot of
fear in terms of security and I think
the model that we have had of society
social market economy liberal democracy
hasn't delivered for everyone and my
argument is that we need to address
these issues but we cannot do it in an
aggressive fashion and that's why I'm
now standing on the barricades to try to
first talk about values because they are
the anchor of what we have and then
tried to do policies on the basis of
those values also where the populace are
doing the explanation
you just gave us a zone is one hand the
other one is that's not an argument
ation to vote for parties who are racist
xenophobic nationalists so this is a
political reality and you know what we
did in Finland we actually hug the
populace to death you might remember
that in 2015 they came into government
and they had three promises no more
austerity no more money degrees and no
more migration what happened we had to
push austerity we bailed out Greece and
then for a historical reason we had the
biggest migration crisis ever their
popularity halved they split us a party
and now there are the government so
that's one solution but not you know but
you want to be the president of you my
point is that I have dealt with populist
before and I will deal with populist in
the future as well this is what their
most populist yes just an extent is is
he a dangerous populist I have made it
clear that I don't like his illiberal
policies I don't like his attack on
academic freedom or on freedom of NGOs
or on freedom of press but he is even
one of the groups in your IPP are you in
favor and this is possible it's not as
complicated than in the u of excluding
urban Swedish party from the EPP your
family yes and the way in which I would
suggest that we go through it this one
have a dialogue to have a declaration on
values and if Orban and finnish does not
sign that declaration of values then
they're out Viktor Orban is and has been
also prime minister of Hungary has been
reelected should hungry be punished by
the U for its anti-democratic behavior
yes that's why we have article 7 that
has been put into motion this is what
the European Union is all about you have
to basically show that you put your
money where your mouth is you spoke
about some reasons not arguments but
reasons to understand populism Italy now
has a populist anti austerity government
it has recently approved new budget with
massive new borrowing they are breaking
the rules of eurozone countries aren't
they yes they are and that's why I've
always been very strong on a rule
based system the stability and growth
pact and I think when you are in bad
economic times you should be expand
Cherie when you're a good economic times
you should probably do the structural
reforms and I'm quite sadly and a bit
scared to watch what's going on in Italy
at the moment what would be your
reaction on Italy oh it would be one to
follow the rules so I would be very much
the guardian of the treaties on this
particular case on the other hand you
know that austerity for example in Spain
or in Italy we have there a lot of
unemployment use unemployment so poverty
on the one hand and principles on the
other end what is more important they go
hand in hand basically you need to have
structural reforms in place you need to
have an economy that works in order for
you to be able to feed the welfare
society it's not a give and take it's
not only about growth or austerity you
need both you said our values are under
attack from both inside and outside of
the European Union which attack is more
serious and dangerous I think they're
both dangerous you know the way in which
President Donald Trump is acting at this
particular moment China which we
discussed earlier I'd much rather we do
the good guys do the algorithms than the
Chinese and then of course Russia so
that's the attack from the outside and
then from the inside it's also worrying
you know I do think this is a big
problem that's why we need to try to
address it whether it's from Italy
Poland Romania or Hungary it's something
that we need to deal with if we stand
true to our values there was a time
where we wouldn't have said outside the
United States what change I think the US
administration changed you know we have
a president right now in the United
States who is quite unpredictable does
this mean that we are stopping margins
yeah Obama it's only I think hungry yeah
when it comes ya know when it comes to
European policy we're quite predictable
when it comes to trade when it comes to
foreign and security policy when it
comes to crisis management when it comes
to believing
who are not credible no a lot of these
counties are not credible anyway what is
the difference between mr. Albin and mr.
Trump regarded the fact that it's a
small country in a big country
well obviously mr. Orban is a Prime
Minister Donald Trump is a president of
the United States when it comes to
values they probably have a lot of
similarities but mr. Orban is not Europe
he comes from a country of ten million
people which is great in and of itself
but Europe is much more than one
specific member state member states are
going into the direction of
totalitarianism of the destruction of
the rule of law the freedom of press
this is the easy part of Europe and this
is exactly the reason that someone it's
to stand up on the barricades and defend
European and global values wouldn't you
agree
this is mr. Weber no it's me Alex
understood thank you very much for being
on connect Excel
[Music]
you
[Music]